did you have like a
a creative approach to making a music
video where
you'd like to send in the footage from
different parts of the world
uh no no so i with music all the music
videos like
we'd meet up oh great for the music yeah
for the music videos we meet up
and uh i remember um when i met
offset he was just off his face man he
was just
[ __ ] just gone by he was just like yo
like i was like why
yeah i was like he wasn't even speaking
english to me
but uh as soon as we played the track he
was like oh
yeah he's just jamming out
and as soon as the music stopped he just
just sat down and just
went back into his shell yeah what power
to it man
that's where that yeah
dude